Star Fox zero for the Wii U has finally
come out my gosh that took forever so
many delays I'm a huge Star Fox fan if
you guys didn't know you probably Diggs
I wear starfox shirts all the time
I've loved Star Fox for quite some time
almost 20 years and I've been very
excited to play Star Fox zero for a long
time and I finally got my hands on it
let's talk about it but first a story
don't worry it's a good one when I was a
kid my favorite thing was basketball
basketball basketball basketball when I
was in elementary school Michael Jordan
and Scottie Pippen those guys were my
heroes basketball all the time played it
at recess constantly obsessed with it
and for the longest time I asked my
parents to buy me a basketball hoop I
wanted a basketball hoop in the driveway
that was my big request for like six
years and for those years a substitute
for a basketball hoop wore those little
suction cup hoops with the foam balls
man now those were a good time we didn't
really have a lot of money so it took a
long time my parents finally one day
surprised me with a basketball hoop in
my driveway I was so excited I play
basketball every day every day I came
from school basketball friends came over
let's play basketball guys let's do it
due to finances we unfortunately had to
move to an apartment which meant that I
couldn't keep my basketball hoop and I
only had it for like two months so I was
naturally devastated my parents felt bad
and to make up for it they said we'll
buy you a Nintendo 64 and I was like I
don't care anymore
it's everything's fine and because I
played this game particularly often at a
kiosk at my local Blockbuster I
requested starfox 64 which was my very
first video game I ever got so Star Fox
is kind of special to me which is why I
was so excited for Star Fox zero it's
the same rail-based game where you're in
an arwing or some other vehicle and
you're forced to propel forward and
destroy as many enemies as possible and
then there's a boss at the end and you
have your teammates falco peppy and
slippy and special people show up like
bill and cat of course bill
is that you
ooh I can't believe it and it's our four
heroes job to save the lylat system from
the evil and Ross's grasp once again and
we got a lot of the same banter back
which is just beautiful to see don't go
too fast malko I guess I should be
thankful oh I'm hit I didn't expect to
have to use this you're very lucky
Wow so there's a ton of nostalgia that
comes with this game immediately it's a
lot of fun it's very similar to starfox
64 in almost everything in fact in some
ways a little too similar many of the
exact same lands are back again and
sometimes the exact same thing happens
at the exact same land for instance in
the original Star Fox 64 you could lose
track of slippy and he could get
stranded on titania in this game Pepe
gets stranded on titania certain things
happen that happened exactly in the
exact same way exactly as Star Fox 64
exactly and that was just a little
disappointing to me because I do love
nostalgia but I didn't want the exact
same things to happen in the same way
over and over again just like in Star
Fox 64 but there are innovations this
time around one of the biggest ones is
the control system and it's turned off a
lot of gamers and I have to be honest I
do wish there were more options it's
very intuitive there's tons of things
you can do it's a motion control system
in which you use your gamepad to aim
your reticle as well as the control
sticks to aim and move your ship now
this can get very difficult at first it
takes some getting used to
but we live in a world where everyone
wants everything right now if I don't
like this right now I'm never gonna like
it I don't have patience I can't stick
with it but I've stuck with it and I
would say after about three hours of
playtime I was starting to get good at
it but that's also a nice way to say
that you can get used to anything
annoying if you put up with it for long
enough that's also a little bit
disappointing I do wish that the motion
control element was an option you could
turn on or off they kind of act like you
can by making it so you can slightly
turn it off and only use it when you're
aiming but when you're aiming is when
it's most annoying and so you really
can't turn it off Nintendo could fix all
of that if they just released a patch
with the ability to turn the motion
controls off and just have straight-up
control
controls which is old-school and so I
guess in a way I feel bad because I'm
saying that the one thing Nintendo tried
to do differently I'm telling them to do
it the old way it's like I don't want
them to do anything new or different so
I feel kind of icky the fact that I'm
saying just make it like it used to be
because to be honest sometimes if it
isn't broken don't fix it the control
system is a little bit hard to get used
to but once you do get used to it
there's a lot of fun to be had with this
game I love the characters fox falco
peppy and slippy all of them they're
just great and Ross is a fun
entertaining villain this series knows
what it is in regards to just being
silly and over the top and very b-movie
sci-fi like and I love that aspect of
this game it still is a lot of fun to
just mow down enemies and there is a
really good replay value with this game
it really just comes down to some of
those motion controls and some of the
forced ways the game makes you do things
for instance imperative dialogue is
heard from your teammates through the
gamepad speakers not the TV that got a
little tedious because I usually turn
the gamepad down and just use the TV
speakers but you can't there's no option
to change that also the game will
sometimes force you to look at your
gamepad it will absolutely force you to
look down at your gamepad and it will
zoom out from the ship on the TV and you
have no real control over the camera
anymore you have to look at cockpit view
in the gamepad that got really annoying
and I wish that wasn't even in this game
i learned the motion controls i got used
to them that was something i could
figure out but that zooming out on the
TV then forcing you to look down at the
gamepad to your cockpit view which is a
very restricted view that i flat-out
hated and I really wish that wasn't an
option in this game my least favorite
new addition regards to vehicles is the
gyro wing this thing is just broken you
can only go up and down very slowly
forward and backwards very slowly it's a
stealth mission on the zionists level or
zonas and it's extremely difficult to
operate you can descend a little robot
from a string and operate computers
which seems like it'd be fun but it
really isn't that whole stealth mission
really did not like that part of the
game but gratefully you're not forced to
use that ship too often so it's not that
big of a deal for me before I give my
grade for this game though I do want to
and one thing I never really talk about
this something I don't usually do but in
this case I have to because I love the
boxart
for this product so let's examine that
in detail because I really dig it so yes
I absolutely adore this box art it's
incredible I love the artwork
I love the design I love the fact that
it's an old cardboard style box like an
old Super NES game or n64 that is my
favorite part
also this actually does come with an
extra game called starfox guard which I
have not yet played as you can see I
haven't opened it yet it is a tower
defense game and apparently it's fun but
I haven't actually got a chance to play
that yet so I'm not actually reviewing
that game but I love this box I
absolutely adore it it's so nice to look
at I really wish it came with an
instruction manual nevertheless I just
wanted to include how cool that is it
looks so awesome I just I love this
artwork overall I had a great time
playing Star Fox zero it is not a
perfect game it is disappointingly very
similar to starfox 64 in regards to
following the exact same patterns and
very very closely in fact and I kind of
was disappointed by that I was expecting
a little more innovation unfortunately
where they did try to innovate with the
motion controls doesn't always work and
it does feel very clunky and you do have
to play for quite some time to get used
to it and I wish Nintendo would just
release a patch that allowed you to
choose if you wanted to use those
controls or not because some people
really like them and some people really
hate them I'm kind of in the middle if
they just released an option to turn
them on or off that would be perfect and
the problem would be solved overall I am
satisfied with this game unfortunately
it is not the great game I hope for I'm
going to give it a 7 point 5 out of 10
guys thank you very much for watching I
do want to let you know that I'm still
running my promotion with audible.com if
you guys go to audible.com slash Chris
you can get a free 30-day trial in which
you can download audiobooks of your
choice I love the fact that they have so
many Star Wars novels on that site
speaking of Star Wars related things
like Star Fox I love the fact that there
are so many Star Wars audiobooks on this
site I've received so much great
feedback from you guys in regards to all
the things they have available a lot of
people actually used it to download some
school books they needed and that
was really cool to read I love the fact
that you guys are digging that promotion
and I thank audible very much for
continuing to work with me if you go to
audible.com slash Chris like I said you
can get a free 30-day trial of their
service and there are hundreds of
thousands of books and novels at your
disposal go enjoy that that's my gift to
you guys and thank you very much as
always to audible for continuing to work
with my channel and sponsor my videos
you guys are the best thank you so much
as always for watching guys I'll be back
very soon with the review for the
amazing spider-man 2 as well as green
room and I want to review Ratchet and
Clank and I want to review Keanu thank
you so much as always for watching and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes